the number of spare critical care beds  in the NHS is 3413 on the latest figures  there have been 1 million 291,000 tests  for coronavirus including 85,000 186  tests on Sunday yesterday a hundred and  ninety thousand 584 people have now  tested positive for coronavirus an  increase of three thousand nine hundred  and eighty five thirteen thousand two  hundred and fifty-eight people are in  hospital with coronavirus and twenty  eight thousand seven hundred and  thirty-four people have died that's  across all settings an increase of two  hundred and eighty eight that figure is  lower than at any point since the end of  March  but as with testing these reported  figures tend to be lower over the  weekend so we do do expect that number  to rise and remember this is not just a  number but it is a constant insistent  reminder that we must go further and  faster in our national effort in dealing  with this virus